"Pogo Fight Rampage."
What the hell?
Who are YOU?!
Alright, press Space button.
Well...
(laughing) I'm s- terribly sorry about that.
I seem to be doing this the wrong way.
Something tells me I should be stabbing UP the butt         ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
BUT that doesn't seem to be an option here.
'Scuse me, Santa.
Your large carcass is getting in the way of this murder here.
Okie dokie, then.
I don't know why THAT was necessary.
Huh...
Hi, bro!
Um...
Y'know...
as a brother myself, I don't wanna kill you,
'cuz I don't wanna imagine killing MY brother.
Alright, anyway-
(loud, echoing scream)
Oh jeez!
Uh, well, movin' on!
Don't mind me as I-
Whhhhhat the hell?!
Where'd you come from?!
Alright, goodbye, clones of my brother!
It's not the same!
IT'S NOT THE SAME!
(sobbing) It's not the same...
Oh.
Hi?
(Kamehameha, beeotch)
(laughing) What the fuck was that?
Oh, okay!
(laughing) Alrighty then!
We're gonna pretend that was normal...
"Mortal Kombat."
Oh- EUGH!
Hohhhh.
Hiiii.
How's it goin' there, Scorpio?
Hebeskeh!
Alright, 'scuse me, I gotta get by with actual important business to do.
Thank God that wasn't spikes, because I thought I was gonna die.
Ohhhhh...
(realizes) Oh, I see your game!
Oh, shit!
Oh, God!
ooOOOooh!
I have a transparent pelvis, apparently.
Hellooooo~!
Okay, goodbye then.
Please eat my taint as I move along. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Babedabebeda--
ooooooooooooh...
Hey!
Hi, Ermac!
Oh.
(chuckling) He fell in fear.
Or love.
Not sure which.
Habooshki!
That's what you get.
That's what's called a Fatality!
FUCK you.
"Stop Thi-"
I don't feel like we need to kill everybody that wants to be naked.
I feel like that's, you know, someone's...
If people wanna be naked, that's their proclivity!
Okay...
Oww!
I'm broke in half!
Please stop WHAT?!
I just got here!
I'm broken!
Don't make fun of me!
Uhhh...
I don't know if-
I- Hey-
WOAH, hey!
Back off, old man! I'm not into feet!
Alright, you go-
Okay, goodbye!
I guess I didn't have to kill ya!
My natural instinct was to kill you, but I don't know why I...
wanted that.
"Mini Golf."
What the ffffuuuUUUUUCK?
(laughing) Thi-
This isn't exactly mini golf, but I'll take it!
Eheh!
Alright.
Woooo!
I feel accomplished!
Everything's goin' good in my life!
Alrighty then!
Oh, now this one's called "Ultimate Golf De-"
Wow, okay...
That's legitimately golf.
The other one was a bullshit version of mini golf.
This is 100%...
legitimately...
golf.
Okay...
I'm ready.
How do I...?
Do I...
I click?
Oh my God!
(laughing) It IS golf!
It really is golf!
It's frickin' GOLF! (indeed markimoo)
Heh.
It's-
Why did that not go?
It's as frustrating as golf.
Heh-
You son of a tit!
Okay.
Heh.
Eh.
Ohhhh, eat ten diiiiicks.
Heh.
Wow!
Okay!
"8-Bit Mini-"
Oooh.
Insert coin?
Hell yeah!
Oh, hi.
Who the ffffuck are you?
Ahh!
I'm sorry!
Oh jeez!
I didn't expect it to do that horrible of a death for you!
Oh God, I'm not gonna be able to get this.
AH!
Fudger Nutters.
Okay,
heah-
Gotta...
build up the...
PROPER-
fuUUUUCK!
Alright.
Insert the coin.
Well, I can't do THAT right!
I'm a dick.
Alright, gotta insert the...
coin...
There we go.
Alright.
Sorry, Mario!
Er...
Pac- ohhhhhhhhhhhh-
(uncomfortable laughter)
Ohohhh!
Ohhh!
It's just as horrible!
Okay!
Good!
Why do I want the other ones?
This is really cool, by the way!
Two deathszz...
Two- two deathszzzz!
Yay! I don't get the death!
Well, not yet I don't.
Heh!
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Oohoohoo!
Slotted in between the-
fuuuuuck.
TittieeeeeEEEEEES!
Hep.
Oop.
Okay.
Oh f- fu- e- hey!
Awww, dickeroni!
Well, shit-a-balls!
I did NOTHING correctly!
Alright, Mario, you sack o' shit.
Let's try this again.
Hehhhhh!
Eat a diiiiiiick!
Now I have no remorse.
Just a few seconds ago, I had...
nothing but-
Euuugh.
He had a wife.
YAY!
I MURDERED!
Woah, okay.
Alright.
Not in the death.
HeEeEh.
Not in the death!
HeEeh.
Welp, that's in the same hole I did before!
Not in the death...
Not in the-
(heavy breath)
Hetushki!
(laughing) Oh, Jesus!
Not...
in the death!
Heh.
Shit.
Okay, thank you!
Heh!
FuuuuUUUUCK-
AAAAH!!
Owwww.
Oh-
Ohh!
I'm already danglin' by my intestines, which is an amazing factor.
I dunno how that happened.
Shabooski!
This time...
actually winning!
Haboo-
fuuuuck.
Heh!
Goddammit!
NOOO!!
Actually winning.
Alright, I'll take it.
KYURRRRDE-SHMEARDEN!
Okay, I'll take it.
KYORDE-SHMYURDEN!
Alright, Mario...
Good thing I KNOW HOW TO PLAY THIS!
Okay.
Decapitated.
As all should be.
Shpyurgen.
Fuckin'-
FUUUCK!!
HOLD I- ehhh...
Harddeeer than I though-
fuuuUUUUCK!!
This is harderrrrrr than a slam dunk!
Shabooski!
Welp.
Missed ya on purpose.
SHABOOSKI!
Welp.
Alright, just enough.
Oh, don't you-
BE DICK!
Awww, you be dick!
YOU BE DICK!
Shabooski!
Hrra-DA!!
Okay.
EHH!
Okay, not where I-
AAAAAH!
YeeeEEEES!
Why "Oh No-ho?"
Why "Oh No-ho??"
Oh.
OWWWW!
I JUST got he-
OHHH, screw you!
You dickhole!
SLAM THE COIN!
HRRUGH!
Throw-
fuck.
Throw!
Fuck.
Throw the ball-
FUCKING-
Goddammit!
FUUUCK!!
F- slam it!
(Vietnam flashback)
FuUUUUUUCK!!
Slam it!
Shabedabooski!
(OH BABY A TRIPLE)
OHHHH!!
Got 'em!
(OH BABY A TRIPLE)
Triple kill, on one.
Win...
(le gasp)
NOOOOOO!!
Eh...
EAT TEN DICKS!
FUCK youuuu!
THIS IS FUCKING IMPOSSIBLE!! (you dont say)
Hurp-
WHYYY?!
(solemn) I know, "Oh, God."
I know...
Just gotta get...
IT UP!
Why?
Not enough momentum,
that's FUCKIN'-
WHYYYYYYYYY!!
Slam it!
No-
Ugh.
Uuuugh!
Okay.
I did it.
So I gotta...
not- break- mah goddamn legs!
OHHHHH FUCK WHY?!
NO!
GET OUT OF THE WAY!!
Ahhh, fuck you, man!
Ah, it's fucking bullshit!
Goddammit!
Fuck you!
"Super Jetpack."
(outro music starts fading in)
Whoosh-
Oh-
(outro music starts fading in)
(chuckles) Jesus!
Habooski!
OoooooaaAAAAOH!
Hi!
Oh!
Oh God.
Hrah- heh- hoh- heh-
Got it cu-
Oh fuck!
Ahhh.
Heeh!
Oh- Heeh!
Hohh!
Haah!
Hruuhh!
Ah, fuck!
~This is gonna be...
~HAAARD!~
Ah- ah- ah-
AH- AH- AH-
AAAH!  (wapow!!!)
YEAAAAAH!
Who died also there?
There's a lot more body parts than was just me...
This has been Happy Wheels Highlights!
Thanks for watching!
If you wanna see more Happy Wheels right now,
check the description or click the annotation for the full Happy Wheels playlist.
AND if you wanna see more Happy Wheels in the future, please click the Like button to let me know!
Thanks again, everyone!
And as always...
I will see YOU...
in the next video.
Bye-byyyyye! <3 <3 <3